précédemment dans chroniques de profs
les ermites barbus ont pris le contrôle
du monde
il était seul dans le désert ils ont
maintenant des bâtiments ils font du
fromage et s'éduque vos enfants il ne me
reste que 24 minutes pour venir à bout
de leur histoire
bonjour et bienvenue dans les moines
évolution qui est la suite de les moines
origins si vous ne l'aviez pas vu je
vous conseille de la regarder parce que
c'était bien la dernière fois on a
expliqué l'origine des moines jusqu'au
10ème siècle et aujourd'hui on va
aborder leur évolution
c'est plutôt clair comme explication
[Musique]
dans la dernière vidéo on était arrivé
au 9e siècle les abbayes était devenu à
la fois des centres religieux des
exploitations agricoles et des
seigneuries les carolingiens on avait
fondé un sacré paquet et elle était
désormais unifiés sous la règle
bénédictine jusqu aux invasions vikings
qui avait un peu freiné les choses
certains moines s'enfuit alors en
emportant reliques et manuscrits avec
eux et parfois ils les vendent au
passage le monachisme été aussi
affaiblie à cause de quelques scandales
de l'église comme le nicolas isme des
clercs qui ont prononcé les voeux mais
qu'ils font quand même la chose c'est
quoi la chose tu es trop jeune et en
plus les rois ou prince qui avait fondé
les abbayes commentait de plus en plus à
s'y sentir chez eux avant jusqu'à nommer
les abbés parmi les copains parfois même
des laïcs qui ne s'installait même pas
dans l'abbaye
mais qui ont touché les revenus quand
même faut pas déconner les abbés devait
payer des troupes si le roi décidé de
convoquer lost l'armée pas la série à
rallonge et devait même accompagné ses
troupes
bien que le mma ou toute autre forme de
combat ne soit pas leur spécialité
en réaction à tous sa 10ème siècle les
abbayes cherchent de plus en plus à se
coaliser et obtenir au passage quelques
privilèges royaux voire mieux pape au
chapeau c'est donc le moment de parler
de cluny monastère bourguignon fondée en
910 par le duc guillaume d'aquitaine et
mis sous la protection de saint pierre
et qui donc est le successeur de saint
pierre en terme d'autorité le don cluny
se placent direct sous l'autorité du
pape en snobant totalement les évêques
qui se trouve entre les deux ce qui lui
permet d'obtenir quelques avantages de
ce dernier en 932 le pape jean 11
confirme l'exemption de l'abbaye de
toute autorité autre que la sienne
contre le payement de dissoudre tous les
cinq ans plus encore le pape interdit
d'excommunier tout moines de cluny et
donne aux abbés de cluny le pouvoir de
réformer les abbayes qui le demandent et
qui deviennent alors rattachée à cluny
j'ai pas compris
imagine que tu es un petit monastère
admiratif de cluny et qui voudraient
rejoindre son clan je suis un petit
monastère admiratif de cluny et je
voudrais rejoindre son clan ta réforme
c'est maintenant
[Musique]
du coup les abbés de cluny sont tout le
temps sur les routes pour réformer tout
les abbayes qui le demande en 1049 cluny
ainsi 40 petite soeur un peu partout en
europe mais passe à 1450 à la fin du
xième siècle efficace chatah pays
affiliés au prieuré reste sujette à
l'archi ab le boss de cluny tellement
puissant qu'il rend jaloux les évêques
les autres habitent ce qui fait que
certaines abbayes décide de reprendre
leur indépendance par la suite chaque
monastère est à la tête de seigneuries
ce l'opulence la particularité de cluny
et de développer très fort la liturgie
au point d'en faire l'activité
principale des moines les travaux
manuels sont reléguées aux frères
convers ce qu'on verra par la suite ou
auxerre et autres salariés labit même la
retraite et la méditation des moines
passe au second plan ils peuvent chanter
juste que 150 psaume par jour pour
compenser tout ça ils améliorent un peu
leur alimentation comme je l'avais déjà
dit dans ma vidéo sur l'alimentation au
moyen-âge et ont même le droit de boire
un petit peu d'heures en résumé ils
passent leurs journées à boire et elle
chante et j'en connais qui vont attraper
une bien piètre réputation pour moins
que ça ouais enfin plus chanter que
boire quand même
lc pour le salut des gens plus ni rend
aussi importante la nécrologie
quand un membre meurt on l'écrit dans le
nécro loges pour les adressé des prières
et on donne son repas à un pauvre
pendant huit jours après le décès puis à
chaque jour anniversaire de sa mort mais
comme le temps passe et les moines ne
sont pas éternels on est bien obligé de
diminuer cette générosité au bout d'un
moment ce nom il ya plus rien à manger
et enfin les moines de cluny sont des
lettrés et ont des ateliers de copiste
fort réputé qui enrichissent la
bibliothèque de cluny et celle à qui ils
vendent leurs manuscrits par contre
niveau école et activités
intellectuelles s'est pas encore les
meilleurs
j'ai dormi dans ma
[Musique]
d'autres monastères décident à leur tour
de fonder leur communauté de leur côté
c'est le cas des chartreux qui ne sont
pas des chats gré soyeux mais une
communauté fondée par bruno comme les
premiers moines il commence par se
retirer du monde avec quelques copains à
la fin du xième siècle puis fonda
monastère avec une règle très austère
son but est de retrouver la recherche de
solitude des moines et pour cela ils
vivent dans des petites maisons autour
du cloître pratique le voeu de silence
quasi perpétuel et ne sortent pas du
monastère en 1300 il ya environ 300
chartreuse qu'on appelle aussi hermitage
ce qui montre bien la volonté de vivre
plus c'est le seul ordre qui n'a suivi
aucune réforme depuis le moyen-âge mais
moins dix vivent toujours dans le
silence à sur leurs revenus par la
ventes de liqueurs et l'ermitage
principal est même interdit de survol
pour éviter tous bruits extérieurs
peut-être qu'ils savent pas qu'ils
vivent au 21ème siècle alors peut-être
qu'il croit que c'est dangereux de
sortir de leur monastère
peut-être que c'est patrice d'un film
qu'on a déjà vu non il existe d'autres
congrégations qui comme les chartreux
commence souvent par un moine un endroit
désert de l'inspiration au xième siècle
le sait nos bêtises me revient à la mode
on veut revenir aux sources rester
pauvre manger et s'habiller simplement
de petits groupes de moines s'installent
sur des terres donner un seigneur est
certaine de naissance à des ordres
monastiques
c'est ainsi qu'apparaît l'ordre
cistercien souvent considéré comme le
grand concurrent de cluny à la base
robert de molesme est un abbé qui décide
de quitter son monastère pour fonder une
communauté termites à la fin du xième
siècle quand 1098 il fonde une abbaye à
cîteaux et il n'en repartira pas de
sitôt l'abbaye restent isolés et austère
les moines vivent dans des huttes
il meurt et se renouvellent très peu
jusqu'à l'arrivée du successeur de
robert bernard de clairvaux qui entre au
monastère avec trente parents et amis
des femmes qui font d'un monastère
féminin à côté à partir de là c'est la
start up nation des 1115 il existe
quatre nouveau monastère et 700 en 1300
les statuts de l'ordre sont appelées la
charte de charité et sont très sévères
contre toutes formes de richesses
les idées principales sont la
revalorisation du travail manuel qui
passe par le refus des dîmes les moines
exploite eux mêmes leur terre via les
frères convers qu'ils sont des moines
mais pas complètement
il applique aussi la réduction de la
durée des offices qui durait trois
plombs dans les monastères clunisiens
et met en place des chapitres généraux
les sortes de grandes réunions pour
parler de leurs problèmes
le succès de l'ordre cistercien réside
aussi dans le rôle de bernard
il est connu pour s'en prendre à cluny
en disant que seule une vie humble peut
mener à la perfection alors que cluny se
veut plus progressiste unie répond à
bernard sa part en bataille de mots bref
bernard pense aussi que les moines
devait chercher à transmettre la foi
mais pas la comprendre ni l'interpréter
il participe à ce titre au procès
d'abélard un intellectuel qui au
contraire penser qu'il fallait analyser
la bible sacrilège pour montrer son
opposition à tony dont les moines
s'habille en noir et décide que les
cisterciens s'habilleront en blanc
et toc bernard parcourt l'europe pour
fonder des monastères il conseille même
des princes est le pape mais il perd un
peu en popularité lorsqu ils prêchent la
deuxième croisade à la demande du pape
et que celle ci échoue monumentalement
mais sa confession d'histoire on a déjà
très bien parlé avec toutes ces
nouvelles organisations une réflexion se
développe dans la société
sur qu'est ce qu'être un moine
finalement le schéma traditionnel de la
société médiévale veut qu il existe
trois ordres
les moines ceux qui prient aurait torres
les nobles qui font la guerre bellatores
et les pécores qui laboure laboratoire
stc dire travail maintenant la bea bon
de fleury aimer une autre hypothèse qui
accorde des bons points aux gens une
fois qu'ils seront morts les moines
arriverait dans l'au-delà avec 100
points alors que les claires on aurait
60 et les laïcs seulement 30 secondes
sam hamad
cela explique pourquoi certains avaient
comme bernard de clairvaux où l'abbé
suger sont vus comme des stars sage et
avisé de toute façon dans les mentalités
l'époque devenir moine devrait être
l'objectif ultime de tout individu
aujourd'hui ces millionnaires les femmes
sont sournoises sauf si elles sont
religieuses ou sainte et qui compte sept
a créé un monastère subirait le
châtiment divin
oui enfin on pensait pas tous comme ça
et en plus incités à devenir moine
permet de freiner la croissance
démographique et préserver les
ressources ce qui se reproduisent pas
pour rentrer au monastère il était
possible de se donner avec ses biens et
ses terres en échange de protection et
de prières cela donne les fameux frères
convers ce dont on a parlé un peu plus
tôt
ils ont trop malastare à l'âge adulte et
non pas un statut de moine à part
entière où leur fils souvent les travaux
manuels les autres membres du monastère
sont des enfants qui sont données pour
recevoir une bonne éducation
les oublie les nobles continue aussi de
faire des dons réguliers pour s'assurer
de bonnes prières alors de devenir moine
n'est pas forcément une vocation
quand bernard de clairvaux entre au
monastère avec trente membres de sa
famille il doit bien les convaincre
notamment sa soeur qui était marié
forcément cela modifie un peu ses
relations avec son mari des enfants de
noble de chevalier qui sont donnés à des
monastères n'ont pas forcément leur mot
à dire et ça peut avoir des conséquences
psychologiques pour eux autres lots de
saint-aignan par exemple est un moine
bénédictin du 11e siècle qui traverse
une longue crise existentielle où les
doutes de l'existence de dieu pense que
sa vie n'a aucun sens tout ça parce que
depuis son enfance il est enfermé dans
les quatre murs d'une abbaye dans la
plupart des cas au moyen-age on ne
permet pas aux moines de penser par
eux-mêmes ils sont incités à se
consacrer aux textes religieuse sans se
poser de questions et les ouvrages
entiers présent dans les monastères pose
problème à certains ab qui les accusent
d'être cause de décadence chez les
cisterciens des moines qui aurait
composé des verts crimes horribles
doivent partir dans une autre abbaye ne
peuvent jamais revenir dans leur pays
d'origine
comme j'ai déjà dit dans la première
partie 11e siècle les ermites reviennent
à la mode au point de devenir un groupe
social à part entière
enfin groupe m'avez comprise il peut
s'agir de moines qui va vivre encore
plus reclus d'anciens soldats
deux personnes qui veulent faire
pénitence on les reconnaît alors à leur
barbe et à la mélodie qu'il porte une
tunique de laine non teintées ou de pots
blancs activités son livre prier
conseiller ceux qui viennent les voir où
prêchait s'ils ont beaucoup de visiteurs
le peuple vénère sésame au point de
construire des chapelles sur le lieu où
un ermite a vécu parce qu'être ermite
n'est pas définitif
si le gars en a marre ou a terminé sa
pénitence il coupe ça barde dans les
flammes et lot et retrouve le monde
il remet des vêtements autres avant la
popularité des ermites permet à deux
personnages en particulier de donner
naissance parfois malgré eux à des
ordres mendiants et c'est qui ces
personnages top jeunes et en espagne en
1170 parcourant le land pour prêcher
contre le catharisme je m'installe
finalement à toulouse en 1215 et font de
l'ordre des frères prêcheurs avec
l'autorisation du pape
plus connu sous le nom de l'ordre
dominicain je suis je suis je suis
dominique à je l'avais presque
saint-dominique accordent de
l'importance à deux choses les études et
la prédication la prédication se fait
dans le but de répandre la foi et la
morale et se fait en imitant la vie des
apôtres c'est à dire en pratiquant
l'itinérance et la mendicité
les frères qui sont tous égaux voire
alors les couvent dominicain comme des
lieux de formation et de ressourcement
et pas des résidences les couvents
prennent le nom de studio les novices
peuvent y faire leurs études
théologiques au cours du xiiie siècle et
pose les bases des études secondaires en
les organisant et en installant des
studios dans des grandes villes qui
deviennent par la suite des villes
universitaires
paris haufor barcelone montpellier ont
chacune un studio mme qui attire des
étudiants de toute l'europe
mais l'histoire des universités est une
autre histoire qu'on abordera peut-être
un jour plus en détail l'ordre
dominicain se caractérise aussi par le
refus de la propriété
seule la possession du couvent sa
chapelle son jardin et quelques livres
pour la formation des moines sont
tolérés mais les moines sont incités à
mendier leur nourriture et leur logement
une branche féminine apparaît rapidement
qui se rapproche un peu plus des
monastères classique mais qui se
consacrent entre autres à convertir
d'anciennes prostituées en monial et
l'autre ordre je suis né en italie en
1182 issu d'une famille bourgeoise jeudi
de me faire ermite à l'âge de 25 ans
elle suit déshérités par mon père aidant
les pauvres et des lépreux restaurant
des chapelles je rassemble rapidement
autour de moi un groupe de compagnons et
décide de leur donner une règle de vie
basé sur la pauvreté et la prédication
mon ordre s'appelle frère de la
pénitence ré mineur ou encore frères
franciscains je suis je suis 36 françois
c'est pas juste
saint françois d'assise encourage encore
plus que les franciscains ses frères à
mener une vie simple et n'exige de
aucune formation ni qualités
intellectuelles rejette les études leur
fait revêtir la tenue traditionnelle des
pauvres d'italie une robe brune à
capuchon et une corde en guise de
ceinture et il aimait les canards
apparemment jusque 1229 les franciscains
envoyés en france et en allemagne sont
considérés comme des hérétiques
on retrouve ce questionnement sur la
place des franciscains parmi les autres
ordres religieux dans le livre et film
le nom de la rose guillaume de
baskerville est ce ton disciple des
franciscains sont envoyés dans une
abbaye bénédictine pour enquêter sur une
mort suspecte
on observe déjà là les différences entre
les deux ordres jusqu'à ce qu'un
inquisiteur anciens dominicain débarque
et se met à parler des résilles en effet
beaucoup s'inspire de saint françois
pour adopter le mode de vie franciscains
mais tout en restant lalique et marié un
ordre féminin les clarisses apparaît
rapidement il fait voeu de clôture
perpétuelle sont enfermés quoi on
imagine un peu mal des femmes parcourir
les routes et prêcher bandits et au
xiiie siècle déjà qu'aujourd'hui c'est
chaud alors 1 à la fin du xiiie siècle
l'ordre et organisées composées de
différentes maisons hiérarchisé et ça
crée un conflit interne sur la place de
la pauvreté dans l'ordre le successeur
de saint-françois étant accusé de trahir
la volonté de saint françois
l'activité intellectuelle de l'ordre
progresse malgré les divisions et l'un
des dirigeants suivants aux gens de
parme rédige même une nouvelle vie de
saint françois qui arrange un petit peu
plus ses affaires
ce dernier dépassés par l'ampleur que
prenait son mouvement et par
l'organisation qui se mettait en place
s'était depuis longtemps retiré des
affaires il consacre la fin de sa vie à
la méditation et auraient bénéficié de
quelques miracles qui lui valent d'être
canonisé
deux ans après sa mort il aimait
toujours les oiseaux à je comprenais pas
aussi pourquoi ils avaient tous un comme
prénom à chaque fois c'était pas leur
prénom d'autres ordres mendiants moins
répandu apparaissent comme les
carmélites les augustes à leur succès un
piètre le berger des villes qui les
voient comme des concurrents mais ils
sont rapidement soutenu par les papes
qui les récupèrent en disant que ça fera
un bon outil de prédication pas cher
malgré la popularité de ses ordres en
rupture avec tout ce qui se faisait en
matière de mode jusque là les ordres de
cluny et de sitôt continue de prospérer
on a donc au xiiie siècle une diversité
religieuse plus forte que jamais juste
avant que les moines commencent à perdre
leur influence au 12ème et 13ème siècle
les monastères étaient au sommet de leur
gloire aussi bien au niveau spirituel
politique économique mais à partir du
13ème siècle leur rôle commence à être
réduit au social et au religieux
uniquement jusqu'à aujourd'hui mais
c'est pas fini
avant de dire au revoir à nos chers
monastère voyons un petit peu plus en
détail ce qui s'y passe indépendamment
des périodes et des différents ordres
religieux
généralement les monastères s'installent
dans des sites agréable comme des valets
déjà exploité par l'homme il ne
s'établissent en forêt que dans l'idée
de la défricher
leur but n'est pas de vivre isolé loin
des hommes puisqu'ils sont souvent à
plus ou moins long terme à la tête d'une
seigneurie et parfois un petit bourg se
forme autour du monastère
ça dépend des ordres les chartreux
s'installe toujours près des villes et
les cisterciens se met plus à l'écart et
renault mais chaque fois le lieu où ils
construisent leurs abeilles et puis
détails pratiques ils s'arrangent pour
avoir de l'eau pas loin aux 5e et 6e
siècle les moines dormait encore dans
des cellules isolées qui se transforme
par la suite en dortoir c'est aussi à
cette époque apparaît le cloître - les
moines sortent plus leur faut de la
place à l'intérieur vers 820 et rédiger
le plan de saint gall un monastère qui
se veut un modèle pour les créations
l'intérieur on y trouve la répartition
de chaque bâtiment avec le scriptorium
la salle de réunion une galerie le
dortoir au deuxième niveau le réfectoire
côté sud
il reprend en gros le schéma d'une villa
romaine à des hommes debout autour des
abeilles peuvent exister des prieurés
des constructions plus petit qui compte
4 à 20 moines et qui sont rattachés à
une abbaye pour s'isoler
s'il s'agit de moines qui choisissent de
livres encore plus en est remis
ou pour mieux contrôler les terres de
l'abbaye ils ont aussi une fonction
d'hospitalité et sont plus proches des
gens meurent et pcr souvent à la
paroisse on trouve aussi parfois sous la
juridiction d'une abbaye desgranges qui
sont confiés à des moines ou des
hôpitaux qui servent aux voyageurs
pauvres ou aux pèlerins j'ai déjà parlé
un peu des différentes personnes qu on
trouve dans les monastères
il ya des oblats les enfants donnés par
leurs parents les converse qui sont
souvent il est trés n'ont pas tous les
droits des moines mais il s'occupe de
l'administration des terres et des
travaux manuels quelques laïcs aussi qui
décide de venir vivre comme des moines
sans être moine
on les appelle atsuko la nomme ce sont
souvent des personnes âgées qui décide
d'entrer au monastère à la fin de leur
vie pour s'assurer une bonne place
après la vie ça me paraît un peu vaine
son nom ce leurre veux juste avant de
mourir
mais s'ils survivent ils doivent quand
même maintenir la promesse dommage
et puis il ya les familiers des
serviteurs de cuisiniers des laïcs qui
peuvent être soit payé soit bénévole
rappelons aussi qu'il existe beaucoup
d'être dans les monastères féminin
puisque les femmes ne peuvent pas
effectuer autant de tâches
administratives ou religieuse que les
hommes
et puis à les moines quand même parmi
eux se trouve la baie et tout un tas
d'officiers monastique qui sont là pour
l'aider
le prieur qui est un peu son bras droit
le cas meyriez qui s'occupe des revenus
des objets précieux
l'hôtelier qui comme son nom l'indiqué
accueille les autres lots money qui fait
l'aumône au port le célérier qui veille
à l'approvisionnement le grainetier une
s'occupe du grain et l'infirmier je vous
fais un dessin levine qui est chargé du
vin ce qui est un petit peu la tâche la
plus importante avec le réflecteur gay
qui est chargé du réfectoire manger et
évidemment on trouve aussi l'art marius
qui gère la bibliothèque et ses petits
amis les copistes mais on en reparlera
très bientôt
suspense suspense est enfin le chantre
qui s'occupe de la liturgie
généralement on considère que pour faire
tourner une abbaye il faut un abbé et
douze moines comme jésus et ses 12
apôtres
mais on trouve des abbayes qui explose
ces chiffres comme cluny qui compte 300
à 400 moines les tâches des moines sont
diverses
ils assurent le service liturgique
quotidien le dimanche les jours de fête
et sont aussi chargés du service
paroissial dans leur seigneurie et sinon
ça peut aussi être eux qui installe le
curé dans la paroisse seront les
fournissant un revenu et tout ce qu'il
faut pour vivre il s'occupe aussi des
prières pour les défunts à partir du
nécro loges qui s'étoffe de plus en plus
au fil des années ils ont aussi
un rôle d'éducation et de culture via la
formation qui fournissent aux enfants
placés dans les monastères le temps de
leurs études uniquement et grâce aux
bibliothèques et scriptoria qu'il
possède les moines copistes recopie des
manuscrits religieux de plus en plus d
ouvrage antique ce qui est un travail
très long puisque un manuscrit peut
prendre plusieurs mois à plusieurs
années à être achevés mais on en
reparlera très bientôt puisqu'il paraît
que la prochaine vidéo de cette chaîne
sera une collaboration sur l'histoire
des bibliothèques mais on en fait tout
le temps et collab enfin sans vous quoi
avec une autre chaîne jette par invité
pardon bref il peut arriver que les
monastères possède des reliques ce qui
est vachement la classe en terme de
prestige ils le rendent alors un culte
et elles peuvent s'avérer fort pratique
en cas de problème en 1066 l'abbaye de
valenciennes est détruite par un
incendie
pour financer la reconstruction les
moines font alors une grande tournée
avec les reliques de saint-amand et
récoltent de l'argent partout où il
passe donc en gros la journée d'un moine
se divise entre la prière tous ensemble
la lecture de la bible et des travaux
manuels dans des proportions différentes
selon les ordres
la plupart du temps tout cela se fait
dans le silence sauf la m forcément on
distingue alors le silence simple où les
moines par la voie basse et le grand
silence pour communiquer les moines
utilise alors des tablettes ou un
langage des signes très élaborés et qui
diffèrent selon les ordres religieux et
enfin ils gèrent leur exploitation et en
tire des revenus en vendant de la laine
par exemple c'est probablement de là que
nous viennent toutes ces belles images
de fromage et d'alcool vendus par les
moines
mais c'est loin d'être leur activité
principale au moyen âge qu'ils ont
produisent bien sûr ils en vendent
mais les produits actuels n'ont pas
grand chose à voir avec l'ancêtre la
liqueur produite par les moines
chartreux par exemple mais une mise en
vente qu'au xviiie siècle les moines
sont à l'origine de l'invention de
certains fromages puisqu'il en
produisaient pour eux mais ils n'ont
rien à voir avec la chaussée aux moines
désolé les fromages et bien
effectivement produit par des moines
comme le monde et cas où la chimie le
sont pour la plupart par des moines
trappistes placement produit même pas
les trappistes sont un ordre issus des
cisterciens qui apparaît au 19e siècle
on est donc loin du moyen âge
il commence à commercialiser leurs
bières au début du xxème siècle dans un
souci de monique pour entretenir nos
monnaies
terre et il ne faut pas confondre les
bières trappistes avec la bière d'abbaye
qui comme leurs noms l'indiquent ne sont
pas brasser en abbaye mais elle garde un
lien avec des abbayes existantes ou
ayant existé
et enfin il ya des tas de bière qui
porte le nom d' abbey lee mais qui n'ont
rien à voir avec la choucroute
tu veux dire la bière ne cache pas mes
répliques s'il te plaît en france
puisque la bière d'abbaye est plutôt un
truc de belges on trouve une bière
effectivement brassée en abeilles c'est
la saint wandrille elle est
commercialisée depuis 2016 pour le côté
médiéval on repassera donc je vous
remercie de m'avoir encore une fois
laissé péter toutes vos idées reçues sur
le sujet c'est tout pour moi tu compte
vraiment terminer ta vidéo ainsi prend
une année sabbatique pendant que tu y es
tu te demande pardon
ce n'est pas pour te jeter la pierre
mais je doute que des abonnés soit au
septième ciel avec une telle conclusion
je vois que tu vas arrêter tout de suite
et jérémiades je fais des vidéos pas des
miracles a déjà déplacé des montagnes
pour la préparer pendant que tu restais
là être une plaie ne fait pas croire que
tu as vécu un calvaire pour la préparer
je ne crois que ce que je vois et tu
n'as pas parole d'évangile
tu me dois déjà une fière chandelle que
je reste ici alors que tous les chemins
mènent à rome et par retourne aux i hate
à terre promise
tu crois que tu es en odeur de sainteté
ici je te rappelle qu'il ya quelques
mois je te connaissait ni d'eve ni
d'adam et tu doit son salut qu'à ma
générosité je me lave les mains de tes
problèmes je ne serai pas ton bouc
émissaire si tu crois que je vais te
porter au pinacle
j'enlève mes bras au ciel tellement qu
tu l'emportera pas au paradis vanité des
vanités à kehl et voilà c'est encore le
capharnaüm ça va être la croix et la
bannière pour calmer la petite la vache
jeu beat pas un mot de ce que vous dites
c'est moi la petite c'était plutôt
amusant
oui à dieu
[Musique]
tout d'abord il faut savoir que sony
walkman date restera